how are you doing today sir good man how
are you i want to start with what i'm
sure everyone is saying which is
congratulations on the movie you're
fantastic in it movie is so good um and
that's all the time i have i will see
you later see ya
man
thank you thank you so much
um so uh one of the things that i found
fascinating about this movie is the it
it probably has the least amount of
exposition i've ever heard in any movie
and i'm curious what was it like reading
the script because it's so sparse with
the dialogue and you know what i mean
totally um i mean that's that's the
beautiful part about the book and the
script
is that um
i guess it has a lot more
to to kind of guide you in in the
narrative sense
um but i guess the huge challenge there
for for jane and
and and for the cast and the cruise is
about conveying that to to film um
so yeah there was there were some
challenges that posed posed there but at
the end of the day i think that is the
beauty of this it's um
it's a lot more in the themes and in the
movements and in the the sensation of
that impending doom or anxiety that this
film conveys
that kind of guides you
i know that benedict really went for it
on this one and tried to stay in
character on set what was it like
watching someone or working with someone
who is really
going for it you know method if you will
it's good i mean it has a
it has a necessary domino effect i think
on
anyone who's in his presence you know we
needed
a hostile environment um to to kind of
keep the continuity to this tone
and you know benedict is quite
completely the opposite of his character
phil so it was extremely necessary to do
so
um yeah it helped me if anything
uh i've heard that uh jane will often
ask people to do like in-character
exercises and you know to help you
prepare for the role what was there
anything that you did that she asked you
to do to get ready for this one from the
get-go the audition
that i had with her wasn't your
traditional audition she really just
asked me about my personal interests
but then also told me to
uplift peter into the room and she asked
him questions and about about his
interest about his life
and i think that was a really
beautiful approach it made me feel
extremely comfortable and had a lot more
freedom about it and if anything i feel
like you can prove more about your
abilities or yourself
in improv um
in a situation like that but
and then from from
moving forward into into the actual
production into rehearsals
that's where all of her cards were you
know
dealt to us um for me personally she
challenged me to
go beyond the boundaries of my personal
approach um as we all have one but um
she kind of picked and prodded me in the
best way
and and challenged me to take on new
techniques and you know
re-explore things that i'd already done
in the past that sometimes your pride
lets you think that you've mastered but
you've never really mastered anything we
never know it all and we're always a
student to to the universe and to our
craft so
she reminded me of that and that's
something that i will always um carry
with me
on what day of the shoot did you get
tired of wearing those jeans
those jeans hey they're comfortable
oh they were tired they were tired he's
right they needed to be worn in i want
to ask you um
sort of about the ending um do you think
that peter
actually had feelings for phil
um at the end of the movie because
there's this great shot of him holding
the rope and you know thinking about
stuff i'm just curious what your take on
it was yeah i'm i'm glad that translated
because that's
for me personally what what i was um
trying to convey or just not even not
even convey because i'm not thinking
about the audience in that sense but for
peter he and that situation was
um
kind of missing missing phil
and i think there's a beautiful
conversation there to be had about the
possibilities of you know phil
wasn't such a horrible person to be
around that there would have been more
possibility that there would have been
chemistry there there could have been a
future there that could have been a
quite happy house
but um yeah it's it's it's a tough one
yeah a hundred percent i already got a
wrap i'm just gonna say seriously man
great work thank you for giving me your
time thank you man see you
you